bonjour à tous bonjour et merci d'être
là aujourd'hui
alors je vais vous faire un petit voyage
à travers le temps et l'espace et on va
commencer en 2009 où une personne assez
mystérieuse qui a un alias encore plus
mystérieux satoshi nakamoto a décidé de
en pleine crise financière créé un
système des changes de valeur du cash
électronique
il va créer deux objets le premier c'est
le bitcoin le deuxième c'est la blue jam
dix ans plus tard on y comprend toujours
rien les experts ne savent pas trop quoi
en penser
et les banques s'arracher les cheveux le
seul comme un accord que tous les
experts financiers ont autour du monde
sait qu'ils ne sont pas d'accord entre
eux je m'appelle david prince est et ça
va être ma responsabilité de vous
expliquer un peu ce qu'est la blocs
chaîne et le bitcoin son
mais tout d'abord je vais vous montrer
un objet du commun un objet qu'on
connaît tous on a tous manipulés et que
moi j'aime beaucoup cet objet c'est un
billet de 50 euros
moi c'est un billet que j'apprécie
énormément vous savez pourquoi
c'est un objet que j'aime bien parce que
quand je vais à la boulangerie et que je
m'achète un croissant avec j'ai
l'impression d'être encore plus riches
quand je ressors j'ai un croissant plein
de billets des pièces c'est une corne
d'abondance
le seul problème que j'ai avec cet objet
c'est à dire que je pourrai vous le
donne et si vous voulez mais il va
falloir me prouver une chose c'est que
cet objet là ce billet n'a jamais
financé une activité illégale ou
criminel que ce soit de la drogue du
terrorisme de l' esclavage n'importe
lequel de ces éléments du blanchiment
d'argent
si vous êtes capable de me le prouver je
vous le donne tout de suite et je vois
que personne ne dit rien
en fait c'est impossible on ne peut pas
avec du cash trouver les points de
destination savoir d'où ça vient où ça
va on a que deux informations le premier
c'est le numéro de série qui est dessus
il est unique il y en a pas deux qui
sont acquis sont pareils et le deuxième
est bien en fait c'est la dernière main
que vous avez eue
qui vous l'a donné c'est à dire que moi
par exemple voilà c'était la banque en
guichet alors pour 50 euros c'est pas
très grave mais justement on va
commencer à monter un peu les enchères
et on va prendre ce billet on va le
plier je le mette dans ma main et on va
retourner un peu l'histoire on va aller
sur quelque chose d'un peu plus complexe
on va prendre un billet qu'on n'a pas
trop trop l'habitude nous les français
de voir même s'il existe dans notre
système
ce billet c'est 500 euros et là vous
vous méfiez tous un peu plus c'est à
dire que si je vous le donne est vous me
diriez non pas vraiment je n'ai pas
vraiment envie de la voir et c'est
pourquoi parceque vous méfier parce que
ce billet vous savez très bien à quoi il
est utilisé toute la méfiance que vous
avez autour de ce billet c'est une
preuve que du blanchiment d'argent
passent dans le système monétaire comme
utilisent aujourd'hui
alors c'est intéressant parce que la
traçabilité c'est un vrai enjeu si on
n'est pas capable de savoir combien cet
argent vaut ou d'où il est venu en fait
on est dans un système qui est san et
moi un système idéal ce serait un
système où dès que ce billet est utilisé
pour une utilisation illégale
plus personne n'en veut ça devient
inutilisable
on le sort du système on le brûle on le
déchire on fait ce qu'on en veut essayer
pas de le ramasser c'est un faux billets
donc voilà pas d'intérêt maintenant on
va aller un peu au centre de l'univers
du système monétaire on va aller
regarder le sens du système monétaire et
le sens du système monétaire c'est le
dollar alors le dollar c'est très
intéressant c'est un billet vrai
celui-là n'y a pas de problème vous
pouvez le prendre c'est un dollar
seulement
et c'est une monnaie qui est très
intéressante pourquoi parce que déjà
dans plein d'autres pays
des fois on n'accepte pas la monnaie
locale on accepte le dollar et des gens
qui préféreront avoir payé en dollars
que dans leurs monnaies locales comme au
venezuela et on va y revenir
le dollar s'est c'est un peu le gendarme
de tous les systèmes monétaires et
jusqu'en 70 71 72
il avait un taux fixe par rapport à l'or
le taux c'était une once d'or 35 g deux
enfin une once d'or 35 dollars par don
excusez moi alors on va faire une petite
approximations une once d'or s'est 30,1
grammes d'or
donc on va dire que à l'époque un dollar
un gramme d'or aujourd'hui est ce que
vous connaissez
dans toute la salle le prix d'un gramme
d'or
à l'heure actuelle non je vais vous
montrer pareil la même façon grecs
aujourd'hui un gramme d'or c'est plutôt
50 dollars alors j'ai fait j'ai pris de
la vence
en fait c'est 38 dollar à l'heure
actuelle mais j'ai pris de l'avancé
parce qu'en septembre
là fédéral réserve a émis ce 150
milliards de dollars
il a fait apparaître de nulle part et
pourquoi elle a fait ça elle a fait ça
pour laisser le système tel quel pour
assurer une stabilité du système
pas pour résoudre des problèmes de faim
dans le monde
c'est 260 millions de dollars pour
résoudre la faim dans le monde si vous
avez l'argent vous me le déposer on
résout le problème
non c'est pour apporter de la stabilité
c'est le rôle des banques centrales le
rôle des banques centrales c'est
d'apporter de la stabilité dans le monde
et de nous permettre d'échanger des
choses mais comment on fait dans un
monde stable
enfin dans un monde instable d'être
stable parce que le monde bouge le monde
évolue on est dans une époque
aujourd'hui de remise en cause
c'est ça le principe est pourquoi
d'ailleurs cet or maintenant niveau 50
dollars
en fait c'est très simple il ya plein de
mécanismes mais y en a un qui est
prépondérant sur les autres et ce
mécanisme c'est l'inflation l'inflation
c'est très complexe ça peut venir de
paramètres très différents mais on va le
résumé en une chose sur le prix de l'or
s'est pas vraiment qu'il ya moins en
moins d'or dans le monde sait qu'il ya
beaucoup beaucoup plus de dollars année
après année dans le monde et c'est ça le
problème
donc on est dans un système qui est
quand même un peu pas vraiment vers la
rupture mais pas très très loin qu'est
ce qui se passe quand l'instabilité
l'emportent sur la stabilité
et là on va faire pareil on va changer
de pays et on va aller voir un peu ce
qui se passe ailleurs
alors ce biais là j'ai eu énormément de
mal à le trouver ces 100 bolivar du
venezuela
alors le venezuela c'est un pays qui est
assez spécial qui a vécu une hyper
inflation grandissante et le chiffre est
très complexe à retrouver j'ai essayé de
le chercher j'ai eu trois infos
différentes et vous allez voir c'est
encore plus intéressant de voir les
sources il ya trois sources ya la
première c'est la banque centrale c'est
celle qui les imprime elle elle va vous
dire qu'en 2018 l'inflation a grandi de
130 mille pour cent il ya l'opposition à
ce système qui va vous dire non en un an
un an c'est beaucoup plus c'est deux
millions deux cent soixante mille pour
cent entre yayi mf organe international
par des d'experts café son étude et qui
s'est dit une réponse de normand
c'est entre les deux c'est un million
comme ça ils ont des problèmes avec
personne
ils ont fait un pas vers l'ain un pas
vers l'autre c'est un million alors
maintenant je veux sortir vous inquiétez
pas je vais pas le transformer
alors moi 130000 un million de millions
qu'est ce que ça veut dire moi ça veut
dire ça c'est à dire que là quand même
on a des vénézuéliens qui sont des gens
qui sont pas très bête
ils ont trouvé une nouvelle utilité à
leur billet ah ouais quand le rouleau de
papier toilette c'est moins de papier
que le biais que vous avez dans la main
vous savez très bien à quoi il est
utilisé ses pieds c'est pour ça que j'ai
eu du mal à le trouver
c'est un deuxième problème qu'on vit
avec avec avec ce système là c'est
vraiment l'hyperinflation et ce genre de
système ça ça vous en dit beaucoup plus
sur le système monétaire dans lequel
vous vivez
on a tous un score dans cette salle
aujourd'hui le score de madame c'est le
produit de ses biens ce qu'elle est
capable de gagner tous les ans et son
patrimoine
et c'est avec ça que votre banque vous
dit soit je vous accorde votre crédit
soit joue la corde pas et on joue dans
un jeu en fait où les missions de ces
monnaies là ce n'est pas vous qui la
contrôle et ce n'est pas un système de
collectivités vous vivez dans un système
de carte elle vivait dans un système où
les missions de l'euro vous n'avez pas
voté ce sont une banque centrale composé
de banques qui le choisit pour vous et
ça c'est important
de la même façon la traçabilité de ces
objets là nous en blocs chez nous on a
un livre de comptes transparents et
ouverts
c'est à dire que tout le monde peut
vérifier les transactions de tout le
monde
on n'a pas forcément l'identité des gens
mais on peut voir ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur du système on peut comparer
on peut regarder on peut voir et ça
c'est important parce qu'en fait on est
tous témoin on va faire une expérience
sur le pouvoir du témoin 6 enfin là on
off
là je vous ai montré de l'argent qui
perd de la valeur dont je vais vous
montrer que quand on était moins on peut
faire gagner la valeur si je reprenais
ce billet d'un dollar que je vous ai
fait disparaître et que ce billet d'un
dollar
on va le x 100 voire 1000 voire beaucoup
plus
ce billet vous le voyez tous la télé le
vois je vire son numéro de série c'est
qu'à 0 69 15 988 g il y en a pas deux
qu'on le même numéro de série dans le
monde d'accord ce biais dans l'année on
va le vendre à une vente aux enchères
pour une cause sociale
on regardera quelle association mais
j'en ai déjà qu'ils m'ont contacté et
qui sont d'accord et ce billet je peux
vous parier qu'on va réussir a multiplié
sa valeur par plus de 100 voire 1000
pourquoi parce qu'on le sait d'où il
vient et on sait où il va et c'est ça la
force alors la traçabilité ce n'est pas
qu'une question d'argent
je veux dire on va pas mourir d'un faux
billets par contre on peut mourir de
manger un faux médicaments ou de la
nourriture qui n'est pas à ce qu'elle
est censée être et c'est ça les vrais
défis qu'on essaye de résoudre dans la
blogosphère c'est la traçabilité des
éléments c'est la génération d'objets
uniques digitaux ou pas et celle anti
contrefaçon c'est ça à nos missions
le voyage est un peu terminée là mais je
vais le terminer juste par deux éléments
le premier c'est pourquoi je suis dans
cet univers qui hélas blocs chaîne et
c'est très simple quand j'étais jeune
j'ai vu mon père qui travaillait chez
airbus et qui rentraient tous les soirs
avec les uc crépitaient de passion il
est à la retraite maintenant et il vit
bien sa retraite mais c'est là que j'ai
compris qu'en fait il fallait que ma vie
ce soir une aventure et de l'amusement
et si je suis dans la blogosphère est
aujourd'hui c'est parce que celle
aventure l'aventuré là on est en train
de créer des technologies qui change la
façon dont les systèmes sont en train de
marcher et le système monétaire qui
apporte de l'égalité aux individus et
une meilleure connaissance de par où ça
passe et où ça va et c'est vers là
comptant alors j'en ai fini avec ma
courte présentation
je suis désolé de ne pas vous avoir pu
expliquer tout en détail comment la
baule chaîne fonctionne qu elles sont
moment la minute par minute et ce temps
réel dans lequel on vit mais en tout cas
si vous n'avez pas compris comment la
bloque chaînes fonctionnent vous avez
compris comment le système monétaire
dans lequel vous vivez lui marche
merci beaucoup